glenn greenwald tulsi gabbard and rand  paul have been identified as russian  propagandists by ukraine now is it a  biased list of course it is this is the  ukrainian list and these are three  people greenwald tulsi and rand paul who  have been much more sympathetic to the  russian cause than to the ukrainian  cause but  it just so happens that it's absolutely  correct and the right and left will  sometimes defend russia for different  reasons  the right will often defend russia  because they like  authoritarianism and they like  uh strongmen  the left will sometimes defend russia  because they are against american empire  vaguely and even though russia it was  and wants to be another empire in and of  its own right  a lot some leftists don't care the  revolutionary leftists and they'll still  support russia so it's a very ugly  situation out there